hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start
warning spoilers ahead
today i'm gonna explain a 2018 chinese
science fiction and action movie called
animal world
the movie begins with a man called kaise
who is working a low-paying job as a
clown in an amusement arcade
suddenly the world near him starts to
change into a clown world and kaise
immediately morphs into a killer clown
with two colored swords carried on his
back while people around him turn into
strange creatures and start attacking
him he begins to eliminate all the
monsters with his martial skills turns
out that he has a psychological disorder
which will turn the world around him
into a strange monster world whenever he
gets emotional this illness has occurred
since his eighth birthday when he had to
witness his dad being killed by
strangers and was forced to watch
ruthless clown cartoon movie back to the
real world kaise is approached by his
childhood friend lee joon who currently
works as a real estate agent he proposes
to kaise to put his apartment up for
mortgage to assist him on a mutual
investment at first the offer is
rejected by kaise because the apartment
is the only thing his father left for
him and his girlfriend king who works as
a nurse is still helping him to pay his
mother's medical bills kaise always goes
to the hospital where his mom is being
treated and king's workplace he attempts
to borrow some money from his girlfriend
saying that his mom will be sleeping in
the hallway if he doesn't pay up the
bills but is avoided by king because she
is busy at that time suddenly he
furiously starts attacking a patient who
is trying to mess up with king and
almost kills him
after work king gives the money kaise
asked for earlier but he finally
realizes that he needs to stop being
such a burden he calls legion and agrees
to his friend's previous offer when
asked about the contract legion states
that it is written in english and
nothing needs to be worried about
sensing that something is wrong kaise
tries to call legion but no one answers
the call
the following day he is called by legion
saying that he is sorry and he will do
anything to make it up if he has the
chance this call makes kaiser really
upset and worried he visits the real
estate agency where his friend works
only to discover that lee joon has been
fired two months ago because of the same
reason deceiving his client and then
vanishing after that he is taken by the
same mysterious guide to anderson who
turns out to be kaise's depth owner he
is equipped with a device that can
translate their conversation into their
own language anderson reveals that
legion lost all the money for gambling
in macau and won't be able to pay the
debt thus all the debt will be accounted
to kaise to pay off the interest on the
astronomical debt he has incurred the
businessman offers him to participate in
a game conducted at a cruise ship called
destiny he adds that all kissy's loan
will be cleared if he manages to win the
game but has to face the consequences if
eliminated
before he leaves kaisi confronts king
saying that he will leave for a business
trip and tell her to unhook his mom from
the respirator if he doesn't come back
in a week
kaisi is then gathered with other
participants in a room where they will
be injected with an anesthetic before
they are delivered to the ship
before being injected he suddenly starts
hallucinating again visualizing himself
escaping from that place by using the
stolen car while being chased by the
guards
back to the real world he attempts to
escape using the same method but he
fails what a poor guy
kissy wakes up and finds himself branded
with a number along with other
participants who will play against him
in the game set in the old-fashioned
ballroom of a huge ship as it sails
through the seas by ninth
all players are provided with 12 cards
concerning the images of rock scissors
or paper 4 cards on each image
also players are given 3 stars as their
life in the game that will be worn on
their arms the participants will
literally play a rock scissor paper game
for 4 hours where the loser will have to
give their start to the winner in order
to win players have to play all the 12
cards in the game and still possess at
least 3 stars additional rules are stars
and cards can be traded voluntarily and
players can request another lone ones
because all the players can do whatever
they want in the game thus it is called
animal world
the game begins and kaisi is approached
by a chinese man zhang
he asks kaise to collaborate by
arranging their cards in the same order
then battle together so that they can
tie all the matches and win the game
easily without losing a star kaise
agrees to it and the plan goes well
until zhang decides to betray him by
purposely changing his card's order
which caused skycie a star zhang
apologizes and asks him to play one more
time promising him to give back his star
he accepts and is deceived and fooled by
zhang one more time which makes him very
furious
unexpectedly he meets lee joon again at
the ballroom and starts punching him
ruthlessly legion explains that
eliminated players will be brought to a
room called blackroom where they have
the opportunity to get out from there in
the last 10 minutes after that they'll
be taken to the bottom of the ship and
become lab rats time keeps ticking and
both of them decides to team up they
also bring another chinese man fat t
mang who currently has two starts and
zero cards to join the team at first man
tricks them and steals one of their
cards to play the game but he loses
leaving one star on his arm after some
beating fatty man begs for forgiveness
saying that he has a daughter and his
mom is almost blind they reunite again
and start to plan a strategy
thanks to kaise's talent with math and
probability they are able to pick the
right opponent to play with
on the other side kaise also borrows
money from the loan to buy a star after
spotting the right man and doing an
in-depth analysis about the cards he
might have they challenged him to play
and manage to win 3 stars from him
suddenly a player is eliminated from the
game because he was caught throwing away
the cards into the toilet causing
anderson to shoot him to death after the
incident the team begins to plan a new
strategy because time is ticking and the
cards keep decreasing legion urges the
team to spend the money on cards and fat
man questions him regarding which cards
will guarantee their survival after
analyzing the circumstances kaiser
realizes that paper cards are the fewest
in the game right now and caesar's cards
are the most by assuming that the cards
will decrease at the same and linear
rate paper cards will be the first to
run out because of that kaiser suggests
the team to stock up the rock cards
because they will never lose
long story short they manage to buy all
the rock cards from other players and
wait until the time is right but their
prediction is wrong as paper cards
haven't been decreasing for a while and
scissor cards are dropping fast they
realize that someone is also stocking up
the cards like they do
other team members start panicking and
fatman and legion decides to play the
cards and end up losing and giving away
their stars
a few moments later they are confronted
by luka and his team members
turns out that luca has been monitoring
their movements since kaisi borrowed
money and figured out their strategy
also luka's team members are the one who
beat fat man and lee jun
after negotiating for a while because
time is running out kaisi challenges
luca by betting his three stars and all
the team money for lucas star in one
game
the game begins and it turns out that
kaiser realizes luca has an odd total
number of his cards meaning that he must
throw away the extra card because of
that he already figures out which card
luca will play and manages to win the
game with style
after the game kaise even offers luka's
team member to sell their extra card
which they accept and then leave the
ballroom he then blackmails luca forcing
him to give all his money and cards to
him
suddenly zhang appears again and figures
out kaise's plan he offers kaizee a star
for five specific cards but kaiser
refuses and walks away
besides the card they have currently
there are still 9 rocks 9 scissors and 5
paper cards remaining and they will make
the move after 2 more paper cards are
recycled
zhang launches his plan b by asking all
the remaining players to reshuffle their
cards which will expose kaise's plan
because zhang seems to know all the
players cards they finally decided to
reshuffle the cards the reshuffle has
finished and the remaining players
continued playing the game while kaisi
fatty mang and lee joon are still
gathering their cards after being thrown
away by zhang
a few moments later kaiser reveals to
all players that zhang is a cheater and
tricked all players while reshuffling
the card by marking scissors card
currently kaizee has the largest number
of cards so he suggests fair play by
placing three cards with different
pictures and letting his opponent choose
which card to be opened so other players
want to play with him
unfortunately nobody is willing to play
with zhang anymore thus he is forced to
play with kaise kaise has planned
everything and eventually zhang comes to
the table and challenges him because of
that kaise's team will have an odd total
number of cards which means there will
be a card that will never be played thus
one of them will have to go to blackroom
zhang bets five of his stars and kaisi
manages to win the battle after that
kaise is brought to the black room
hoping that his other teammates will
save him with the money they have at the
black room he meets an old man who has
been deceived by white suited man and is
looking for him
unfortunately the white suited man has
won the game and leaves the old man
alone in the black room the game is
finally over and the players have the
chance to redeem the stars for money or
to help their friends surprisingly
fighting men refuses to help kaiser and
takes all the stars from legion he also
reveals that he was lying about his
daughter and his mom earlier
he then leaves a bag of money to legion
and goes away
as expected legion also acts like an
animal and eventually betrays kaiser
which makes him furious
kaisi spots something being hidden on
the back of a player and starts
attacking him turns out that he manages
to steal a diamond from the player's
back and other players are forced to
release kaise from the black room before
he leaves the old man begs him to send a
message to his son
after being released kaiser immediately
confronts fatty men and launches his
final punches towards him forcing him to
hand over all the stars and money
kaisi then exchanges all the stars to
release the old man because he knows
what it feels to live without a dad and
telling him to tell the message himself
to his son
finally all the winners are released
from the ship and go back to their daily
life
kaiser returns to king and both of them
reunite again at the end of the movie
kaiser discovers that anderson is the
one who broke into their house several
years ago and his father has also
participated in the game
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching